(bright music)
- [Reporter] A federal jury
found Donald Trump liable
for the sexual abuse and defamation
of writer E. Jean Carroll and ordered him
to pay $5 million in damages.
- [Speaker] How do you feel?
- [Carroll] Very happy.
- [Reporter] Trump called
the verdict a disgrace
in a message on his social
media network, Truth Social.
Corinne Ramey covers
New York investigations
into Donald Trump, and has been following
the civil trial for the journal.
She explains what you need to know
about the case and what the
consequences are for Trump.
(bright music continues)
- This lawsuit was filed
in 2022 by E. Jean Carroll,
a writer and advice columnist.
She alleged in the lawsuit
that Donald Trump raped her
in the dressing room
of Bergdorf Goodman's,
a Manhattan department
store in the mid 1990s.
- He put his shoulder against
me to hold me against the wall
and at that point, I realized
that I was in a very difficult situation.
- Her lawyers tried to show
that Trump had, what they call, an MO,
that he sexually assaulted
women in similar ways,
and they did this through both
the accounts of two women,
but also by playing the
2005 Access Hollywood tape.
- [Trump] You Know, I'm
automatically attracted
to beautiful, I just start kissing them.
It's like a magnet.
(person laughs)
You just kiss.
(person continues to laugh)
I don't even wait.
And when you're a star,
they let you do it.
You can do anything.
- [Speaker] Whatever you want.
- Grab 'em by the.
(person continues to laugh)
You can do anything.
- Trump's side chose not to
present any witnesses at trial,
but they said one reason for this
is because his defense was,
essentially that it never happened,
that her story was a
lie, it was inconsistent.
Trump has said he doesn't know Carroll
and that he's never met her.
- [Prosecutor] Now, when you say in here,
"I don't know this woman,
and have no idea who she is,"
even though you're
using the present tense,
you're referring back to your knowledge
as of when she first made the allegation.
- I still don't know this woman.
I think she's a whack job.
I have no idea.
I don't know anything about this woman
other than what I read in
stories and what I hear.
I know nothing about her
- In the lawsuit, she also alleges
that Trump defamed her in
a 2022 social media post
in which he called her
account a hoax and a lie
and said, "She wasn't my type."
Carroll asked for damages for
both defamation and battery.
One of her lawyers said
in a closing argument
that for aging Carroll, the
case was not about the money.
For Trump, the immediate impact
is he'll have to pay the damages
that were ordered by the jury.
- This was a rape claim.
It was a rape case all along
and the jury rejected that,
but made other findings,
so we'll obviously be
appealing those other findings.
(crowd cheers)
- [Ramey] He's also sure to
face questions about the verdict
as he continues running
for the 2024 Republican
presidential nomination.
It just compounds the various legal issues
that surround him right now.
(bright music)